[Music]
this is my cell phone okay does that
look like that is the cell phone case of
a liberal
[Music]
my dad is a retired Baptist minister he
told me that in order to get people to
hear your message you have to get them
in the church that is a mistake that a
lot of environmentalists make when
talking to Republicans and conservative
about solar about clean energy they lead
off with climate change that is the
wrong message if you deliver the message
of energy freedom energy choice
competition national security innovation
all of a sudden you will have a
receptive audience and they will listen
to you if you lead off with climate
change they're not going to pay a bit of
attention to anything else you say
they've been brainwashed for decades
into believing we're not damaging the
environment unfortunately a lot of the
fossil fuel interest in giant monopolies
have been telling activists for decades
that we're not damaging the environment
everyone agrees that burning fossil
fuels releases carbon dioxide and that
such concentrations in the atmosphere
are rising but it's a long and dangerous
lead to conclude that we should
therefore cut fossil fuel use you have
industries that have a lot of money and
deep pockets and they're willing to use
that money to put out negative facts and
bogus studies to convince us that we
renewables or bad get the facts about
these out-of-state solar companies at AC
solar fact calm and by god they're not
going to get away with it you had to
understand one thing the Republican
Party has always been in the past a
party of conservation Richard Nixon
Republican president actually created
the EPA to make sure
we had clean air and clean water each of
us all across this great land has a
stake in maintaining and improving
environmental quality Ronald Reagan and
not actually known as an environmental
president but he was the conservationist
he actually believed Mann was damaging
the environment and he advocated very
strongly for and signed the Montreal
Protocol that banned fluorocarbon if
Ronald Reagan were alive today and he
wanted to ban aerosol fluorocarbon
because he saw scientific evidence that
they were damaging the environment some
of these same groups that are attacking
renewables would be attacking the
conservative icon Ronald Reagan one of
the reasons I'm fighting very hard to
bring conservatives on board and to
educate conservatives to advance
renewable failure is not an option this
art is not a Republican or it's not a
Democrat or this art belongs to all of
us if you think fossil fuel is not
damaging the environment pull your car
in a garage start up your engine and
inhale the exhaust beings for a few
minutes and see what happens